whoa okay what why would they why do
they put the sticker right over the hey
what is up guys inkay PhD here and yes
the Iron Man Samsung Galaxy s6 edge is
real and this is one of them it's the
limited edition sort of a collector's
item and at the same time it's still a
fully functioning top-of-the-line
smartphone and all the same ways as the
regular galaxy s6 so as you saw the
packaging was pretty fancy and not only
do you get the painted phone you also
get a painted wireless charging pad with
the red and gold theme instead of plain
white and you also get the other normal
Samsung accessories in the box - they
aren't painted also but they still come
in some pretty fancy packaging which I
guess they should come with for the
price you pay for this thing you also
get your normal paperwork a SIM card
ejector tool a little card that says the
Avengers age of Ultron movie is in
cinemas now I heard it was pretty good
and a clear plastic flexible case just
in case you actually end up using the
phone as a daily driver I guess and want
to protect it so the phone itself as
we've all seen in the teaser and promo
material is pretty badass looking it's
rocking that red coat of paint on the
front and the back with a gold color on
the metal side bezels and that Iron Man
helmet painted on the back this is an
awesome combo obviously a pretty flashy
looking phone from pretty much every
angle and since the galaxy s6 has so
much you know reflective glass and metal
it's one of the most eye-catching phones
I've ever seen you may also notice that
limited edition print on the bottom not
sure how many of these are actually made
but there are only four digits and yeah
this is just not your average looking
smartphone and it's not just the
hardware that's unique to you also have
probably noticed this software is pretty
special as well the Ironman galaxy s6 is
rocking an exclusive theme actually a
variant of the iron
man theme that's already in the Samsung
theme store but with gold accents
instead of silver so this theme affects
the whole look of the phone so you know
the wallpaper the lockscreen the icons
everything you look at on the home
screen all of that stuff and it's made
its way actually into stuff like the
stock apps to the dialer it's in the
contacts the messages and it basically
gives them all this red and gold look or
adds like a red and gold background
everywhere there's actually even a new
sound pack with this theme so it's
everywhere and I gotta be honest the
skin itself is not pretty in my opinion
but that's not really why you're here
anyway you can uninstall this theme in a
heartbeat and make it look like stock
again what you really would get this
phone for is a hardware the gold accents
everywhere the solid metal Iron Man
helmet in the packaging and the custom
accessories and everything like that I
mean this is something a collector would
buy and like basically never use they'd
put it up in a glass case on display and
never touch it so that being said if
you're watching this you're probably not
a collector so you've probably looked at
the price it costs to import this and
said nope
not buying that which is a normal
reaction and you can get the regular
galaxy s6 instead but lucky for you I'm
going to give this away and it's going
to be super easy to enter basically if
you're a subscriber of this youtube
channel go ahead and drop a comment
right below that like button letting me
know you want to win it and boom you're
entered that's it it's easy and there
should be two other videos in your
subscription box today for my buddies
John from the TLD Channel and Lou from
unbox therapy and if they're not in your
subscription box you need to head over
to their channels and subscribe right
now too because they are also giving
away ironman phones and you can see
their videos and get entered on theirs
too so yeah we're just making a rain
Iron Man phones over here no big deal
tell your friends if you think they
might want to win one of these and we'll
be announcing the winners on Twitter so
definitely follow over there and all of
the links and information for your
giveaway will be in the description
below so there you have it that's Iron
Men thank you for watching and I'll talk
to you guys the next one peace
you